Київський патріархат був, є і буде -
запевняє почесний патріарх Православної церкви УкраїниФіларет
і скликає собор для його збереження.
Ми не відновлюємо Київський Патріархат, ми продовжуємо існувати як Київський Патріархат.
Патріарх, що відновлюється? Він був, є і буде.
Українська православна церква Київського патріархату фактично проіснувала 16 років.
Під час Об’єднавчого собору торік у грудні наявні на той час в Україні
православні церковні організації Київський патріархат,
Українська автокефальна православна церква та деякі представники Московського патріархату
створили єдину помісну церкву - Православну церкву України.
Її предстоятелем обрали митрополита Епіфанія. І саме ця церква отримала томос про автокефалію.
Цікаво, що перед цим історичним для України зібранням представники Київського патріархату
провели свій собор, де вирішили, що у разі створення помісної церкви
Київський патріархат ліквідовується.
Свій підпис під відповідною постановою тоді поставив і Філарет.
Вже у січні українське міністерство культури видало наказ про реєстрацію Київської митрополії ПЦУ
і про припинення реєстрації УПЦ КП.
Таким чином, припинення існування Київського патріархату було закріплено юридично.
Проте насправді ця церковна організація дійсно досі залишається зареєстрованою в державних органах.
За даними Єдиного державного реєстру мін’юсту,
Київська патріархія Української православної церкви Київського патріархату залишається чинною,
тобто юридично УПЦ КП продовжує існувати і не перебуває в процесі припинення.
Водночас, деякі релігієзнавці вказують, що Київський патріархат
нині представлений на рівні окремих юридичних осіб - громада, монастирі, братства, місії тощо.
Але якщо брати релігійні організації загалом, то оглядачі нагадують,
що релігійні центри УПЦ КП та УАПЦ припинили своє існування, і існує зареєстрований статут ПЦУ.
Та навіть якщо процес ліквідації Київського патріархату не завершений з юридичної точки зору,
до кінця незрозумілим залишається, який канонічний статус має Київський патріархат -
чи це автокефальна церква, чи вона перебуває у складі ПЦУ.
Заяви Філарета щодо чинності Київського патріархату
оглядачі пояснюють його особистими амбіціями.
Адже після створення Православної церкви України
він отримав радше символічний статус - почесного патріарха.
При цьому Філарет не приховує своїх претензій до Епіфанія.
Мовляв, він відійшов від домовленостей, за якими Епіфаній мав представляти ПЦУ назовні.
Тоді як патріарх, за словами Філарета, мав відповідати за внутрішнє церковне життя в Україні.
Юридично Українська православна церква Київського патріархату продовжує існувати
і залишається зареєстрованою у державних органах, у цьому твердженні Філарет правий.
Проте канонічного статусу в цієї церковної організації немає.
Філарет заявляє про бажання відновити Київських патріархат та свій патріарший статус.
Однак найбільше, на що він може розраховувати зараз, зазначають оглядачі, -
це на створення невизнаної церкви.